which one has the advantage mouse and
keyboard or VR nothing keyboard the are
mouse a keyboard
I'd say VR for sure quarter Digital
accomplished towards you have 24 hours
left to get this shirt one of the
coolest shirts I've ever made the link
in the description below
don't delay act today it'll be gone
forever there's a question I've been
really really curious about if you were
to pick a VR player it's a mouse and
keyboard player which one would have the
advantage generally speaking if you ask
any gamer who has advantage of
personality console with a controller or
a person on a PC with mouse and keyboard
99% of people will say the mouse and
keyboard has damaged a mouse and
keyboard looks to be a lot faster a lot
more specific well I want accurate with
your movements with 180 with the mouse
and keyboard with just a single swipe to
the hand you could be accident with a
controller you have to pull the joystick
you need to let it go at just the right
time wait for it to land on your target
controllers are great for when you're
sitting on the couch but then it comes
to being competitive mouse and keyboard
is going to dominate across the board
isn't this question is important is
because the VR markets not that big you
want to have a successful multiplayer
game you need to have a population of
players always playing that game cuz of
you our market is small you might only
have 5 or 10 people playing that game
but if you can open it up to PC players
playing with a mouse and keyboard you
can bring that game back to life and you
can have you know a population of a
thousand people playing now the question
is if you put those players on mouse and
keyboard up against VR players are you
giving the mouse and keyboard players an
unfair advantage or are you giving the
mouse and keyboard players an unfair
disadvantage
I've got clean Adrian we're both very
good at first-person shooters to join me
I'm going to play the VR there give you
a mouse a keyboard and I'm gonna do the
best to try to beat me and
see which one is better come with me now
this totally depends on the players
skill I think you can actually blend now
some cheaper players in VR players and
get away with it somebody who's really
skilled at mouse and keyboard will stand
up to view our players and handle
themselves just fine so here are the
advantages if you're to play a
first-person shooter in VR first off
your twitch aiming is impeccably
accurate there's no sensitivity to worry
about there's no mousepad to worry about
there's no hardware to worry about it's
your body another advantage of VR is
your awareness some B's above you you
look up so he's behind you we turn over
your shoulder so be sure ting at you you
mean behind the wall it's a lot easier
to look around instinctually while
aiming somewhere else while moving
somewhere else
basicly have these three different
control schemes that are all very
natural right as mouse and keyboard like
to this the only way you could win it's
the only way Nikko can win is he picks a
broken game in his favor so that so that
we suck and Nico look appears as if Nico
is shining bright where does that leave
you
Donald Hollinger soda
I'm good
un Nico every day
all right so I dream kill me so much
easier in VR think it goes to shape up a
VR thanks to cake
[Music]
30 boxes this is a good room here take
this one to my face
exactly they are so easy it's games so
easy me up just wait
hardly
it's hardly quite like conducive to this
experiment permeated consensuses the
others definitely easier but I think it
would take a little bit of time to like
get used to the game the game is ours
easier
I had an easier time playing on the yard
that giving the computer it was a lot
more fun yeah that's for sure yeah you
know so we didn't experience in life
so you guys hadn't quit the game before
nowadays a little skewed so now a son
who asked me the game before this I
think in this situation the VR has an
advantage does it technically his first
person oh this is third but I feel like
mouse and keyboard if you like know the
game and you could play it and you're
like you're used to it then I think you
could still probably beat anyone in VR
he's ready yeah you played a bit anyway
so do your thing that mouse and keyboard
superior huh yeah
oh man just at the time before he
disappeared
all right he's got 100 all right well I
guess Amy's easier on VR where it's
definitely really competitive with VR if
you lose first person you'd be very
different
yeah because in third person you're
aiming is like so you're such a wide
field of view or like you've so much for
old vision going on that's like not
concentrated on it and also not really
I'd much rather have a first-person view
with a gun that's right in the middle
that way I can focus and like aim on the
person what I'm noticing though is that
you're aiming and this is like
definitely way more accurate because to
move the gun more accurately while
you're firing because on the keyboard
like the slightest movement like this
and a third person game is like huge
also being with da just breathe yeah I
can take cover way more effectively
honestly they are better than thought of
it being oh yeah P still win yeah well
thanks for a hard to happen they
preserve it I surprised me I'll see you
in a half an hour or whatever for
filming we played many games going back
and forth mouse and keyboard VR mouse
keyboard we are switching people around
hey Nick
and I've come to the conclusion that VR
gives you probably about a 10 to 20
percent advantage now this totally
depends on the players skill I think you
can actually blend now sand keeper
players in VR players and get away with
it I'm here at video game developer here
at VR game Dan offer and you're trying
to figure out a way to keep your
multiplayer populations alive don't be
afraid to blend regular PC players and
fiar players
unless your game is really going to be
pushing itself towards a very specific
style of combat that benefits one of the
two but generally speaking for a normal
first-person shooter the two populations
will blend your VR people will have a
little advantage and you might have to
design around that a little bit but it's
nowhere near the disparity of
controllers versus thousand people I'd
say go for it VR devs go horde game devs
blend the two audiences how cross play
don't worry about it too much let people
have fun controllers a mouse a keyboard
though I think you should probably keep
those separate for a little while longer
is 10:00 p.m. on Saturday night and
nobody is in the studio except for me
and Carmichael the reason why we're here
what no one else is is to tell you that
when this video goes up you have 24
hours left to order the anime
self-driving car shirt that's right is
the last day for you to buy this shirt
there's limited edition print once it is
gone it is gone forever core digital
comm slash store that's what you want to
go if you want to buy a shirt and trust
me this is one you don't want to miss
the best shirt we've ever made also
everything else is doing on the store to
go check it out if you haven't hey free
returns across the board on our store we
want you guys to be happy with anything
you get from us so there's no restocking
fee nothing like that you do not have to
worry about it if the shirt doesn't fit
you go ahead and send it back we will
eat the costs that's right just we're
hungry for my guests go check it out
Korda digital accomplished or it's a
great shirt you don't jump on it now
you'll probably regret it I know I will
but I've already ordered one I'm wearing
it right now